en esta tabla de aquí nos dan un montón
de entradas en la parte superior al 1 2
3 4 y también tenemos a la
correspondiente gdn lo que quiero que
notes a continuación es que esta función
cdn define una sucesión donde n es el
término de la asociación por ejemplo
podemos decir que esta tabla es la misma
cosa que la siguiente sucesión
imagínate tomarte la asociación en el
cual el primer término es 168 168 el
segundo término sería 84 84 el tercer
término 42 40 y vemos el cuarto término
21 21 y así podríamos seguir y seguir y
seguir
y bueno ahora la pregunta va a ser qué
tipo de sucesión es esta observa si
empezamos en el 168 como pasamos del 168
al 84 bueno una forma de pensarlo sería
decir lo que hicimos fue restar 84 pero
la forma adecuada de pensarlo es que
multiplicamos por un medio multiplicamos
por un medio date cuenta que si ahora
queremos ver qué pasó del 84 al 42
también multiplicamos por un medio y de
la misma manera del 42 al 21 lo que
hicimos fue multiplicar por un medio así
que esto que tenemos aquí es una
sucesión geométrica es decir empezamos
con un término y cada término siguiente
es el término previo multiplicado por
algo que llamamos razón común
en este caso estamos multiplicando por
la razón común de un medio
así que ahora la pregunta sería cómo
podemos escribir cdn es decir cómo
podemos definir explícitamente en
términos de n g de n y te encargo que
pausa es el vídeo y pienses en cómo
hacerlo así que lo que queremos
construir es un g un gp n igual y bueno
tomando la definición de una función que
escriba lo que está sucediendo aquí es
decir empezar el 168 y después están
multiplicando por un medio así que es
momento de que lo pienses
bueno pues una forma de pensarlo es
empezar aquí en 168 en 168 ya este
multiplicarlo por un medio cierto número
de veces es decir puedes ver que en el
exponente vamos a poner las veces que
vamos a multiplicar por un medio y
cuántas veces tenemos que multiplicar
por un medio
bueno pues veamos que en el primer
término obtuvimos que multiplicar por un
medio cero veces en el segundo término
tuvimos que multiplicar por un medio
una vez en el tercer término tuvimos que
multiplicar por un medio 12 veces ya que
el cuarto término tuvimos que
multiplicar por un medio una dos tres
veces así que si te das cuenta cada
término que tengamos los tenemos
multiplicando por un medio el número de
término menos una vez
es decir n uno y tú puedes ver que esto
funciona porque cuando n vale uno me
quedaría uno menos uno lo cual es cero
un medio elevado a cero es uno y 168 por
uno me darían 168 cuando n vale 2 me
quedaría 2 -1 lo cual es 1 y entonces
estaríamos multiplicando a 168 por un
medio una vez y llegaríamos a 84 si n
vale 3 me quedaría bueno
3 - 1 lo cual de las dos y entonces
estaríamos multiplicando al 168 por un
medio elevado al cuadrado o dicho de
otra manera estaremos multiplicando dos
veces al 168 por un medio
así que esto suena a que realmente
funciona esta expresión esta sería la
función escrita de manera explícita
ahora también lo puedes ver de otra
manera puedes decir que cdn y solamente
voy a usar un poco de manipulación
algebraica es lo mismo que bueno este lo
puedo pasar arriba y me quedaría 168
entre entre 2 elevado a la n menos 1 lo
único que estoy haciendo es escribir la
misma expresión de otra manera usando un
poco de álgebra otra forma de verlo
sería la siguiente decir v n es igual y
bueno usando las propiedades de los
exponentes podríamos ver vamos a
escribir primero es de 168 168 y ahora
quiero que te des cuenta de qué va a
pasar con esta parte de aquí tengo un
medio elevado a la n-1 lo cual tú sabes
que es lo mismo usando propiedades de
los exponentes que un médium elevado a
la n
un medio elevado a la menos 1 ahora date
cuenta de lo siguiente un medio elevado
de menos 1 estar aquí es exactamente lo
mismo que 2 entonces lo podemos escribir
de la siguiente manera esto me va a
quedar como 168 que multiplica a un
medio elevado a la n que multiplica a 2
y entonces ahora si puedo decir que esto
va a ser igual y date cuenta es lo
siguiente si yo multiplico 168 por dos
entonces me va a quedar a 168 por 2 336
160 por 2 320 más 16 336 336 que
multiplica a un medio elevado a la n es
decir que esta forma es equivalente a
esta otra forma que también es
equivalente a esta otra forma las tres
son expresiones equivalentes y tal vez
ésta se pueda ver un poco más intuitiva
porque decimos que de n es igual a la
cantidad inicial con la que empezamos
un medio elevado a el que sea el término
menos uno pero estar acá es algebraica
mente equivalente así que bueno pues
estas tres son correctas ahora bien
también podemos definir a esta misma gtn
de forma recursiva así que te encargo
que pausa es el vídeo y lo intentes
bueno pues hagámoslo gbn en forma
recursiva como lo podremos poner déjame
escribirlo así head n bueno va a ser una
función y vamos a tomarnos la de manera
recursiva así que fíjate lo siguiente
cuando n vale 1 si n vale 1 si n
vale 1 bueno pues nosotros sabemos que
esta función toma el valor de 168 ahora
pensemos qué va a pasar cuando n es más
grande que uno si n es más grande que
uno y bueno recuerda que estamos usando
números naturales
es un número natural y es un número
natural es decir estamos pensando en los
enteros positivos bueno pues en este
caso que vamos a tener bueno pues vamos
a tomarnos un medio un medio y éste un
medio lo vamos a multiplicar por qué de
bueno del número anterior gdn menos 1
así lo vamos a definir y puedes
verificar que esto funciona porque si en
es uno bueno entonces simple y
sencillamente empezamos en 168 lo cual
lo sabíamos y qué va a pasar si n vale 2
bueno pues g2g de 2 va a ser igual a un
medio deje de 1 071 es 168 y 168 y lo
multiplicó por un medio llegó a 84 así
que vamos bien que va a ser de 3
bueno pues g de 3 va a ser un medio de
dos lo cual sería bueno aquí tenemos que
de 284 y si lo multiplicamos por un
medio llegamos a g de 3 así que estamos
bien esta sería nuestra forma
de definir esta sucesión mientras que
esta es nuestra forma recursiva de
definir esta sucesión